yeah
a little good afternoon [__] I am
saying you got to be prepared at all
times
you don't know when flavors gonna be
ready to [__] get up and tell you
people that for years people contact me
let me know when you're gonna get I
don't [__] know okay it could be when
the hairs all [__] up it could be one
of those days Lisa I asked here we got
to show you people something hold on one
second to get the day start on the right
foot
okay blue cookies I'm [__] believable
sativa with a [__] kick you
understand me
you ain't kicked in the head by a horse
that's what this [__] weed does to
you
I still got some critical mass but we're
gonna show you that with a different
[__] product you know me and leave
want top to the game let's trade of
products this next product we're gonna
show you fits the church to the [__]
T okay cuz you never know when you get a
sudden urge to smoke the [__] boat
you never know you never [__] know
now you are no papers no lighter I got
the solution for you
right not right now I'm just setting the
herb man freely here you go
set the [__] nerve man freely
that's a [__] Thursday afternoon fear
we don't have to wait till for 2090 of
410 this is seven days a week 24 hours a
day we take it to the [__] hoop okay
let's pretend you're one of those dudes
that [__] got cotton chilly in the
[__] coal mine a couple years ago
and this admit is for complaints I have
no respect
I gotta get in touch with the FCC you
let me know when they're gonna fly over
this [__] anyway those three those dirty
little [__] the Mexicans got caught in
that tunnel they're sitting there in the
corner besides food and a piece of ass
and a piece of chocolate [__] cake the
most important thing if I ever got
trapped was to have a week okay and to
have a bar or something this new company
what's the name of the comfortable they
put together a barn live this it's
[__] portable you take this out
bye-bye-bye
you put the band around and it fits in
your pocket like a [__] wallet and it
smokes like a [__] mule you
understand me we're gonna go back to the
critical mass to try it out oh that's
right that's right a bomb that fits into
three and into your [__] pocket
because you never know I'm sick and
tired of you people huh I haven't unit
right who gives a [__] what you got
if you can't spark it what good are you
we're good Ian you ever get those people
I got weed but you didn't ring no wrong
you didn't kind of lightly you're not
ready to run you're not ready to do dick
boy you're ready to do is to stand there
with that stupid look on your face no
more BAM I got the solution your
unfolded out of your pocket you're
spitting it a couple of times to get
some water in there and that's it
listen when you're in the [__] tunnel
with bricks on top of you and nobody's
answering this will save your [__]
life if they could just put a flashlight
in this thing and something to wipe your
ass would be say [__] cave you
understand me and you can even empty it
out real easily I don't like the dark
the dark stuff well you can on the next
one it's a spring so you get a punches
out for you punch is that yeah all the
all the yet when your dog oh that's
right that's right legally say it mr.
[__] knowledge over on the back let's
do this [__] this [__] are you
kidding me
are you kidding me look at that oh it's
got some kick to people our portable
[__] bong especially we live in
California with the earthquakes Jersey
what Isis you know they come in they
start shooting up people you down nine
one one I'm gonna die I don't know what
to do [__] it I know what to do you do a
bong in a portable bong and [__] you
go down into the night like a [__]
soldier when you get the [__] in the
pearly gates you're higher than st.
Peter who's better than you yeah yeah
yeah
somebody's gotta think about this [__]
this is perfect Cubans coming over on
the raft bad they got a portable [__]
rabbit you're in the bathtub bad
horrible [__] bong come on guys I
didn't invent this you know why cuz I'm
too high I'm a [__] [__] this is
the [__] we gotta be working on people
this is American ingenuity right here
come on those things will kill you
and you go like this at the spring BAM
and the week comes right out there you
don't need a poker you don't need
nothing who's got a poker when you
didn't under [__] Lincoln Tunnel
after Isis blows up nobody but you I
don't know where to get this roll roll a
bowl calm tell him uncle [__] Joey
sent you this is the future [__] this
is it you're stuck on a [__] nine
little ships you know those cruise lines
with those [__] jerk clothes yeah
damn
tell him I'm trying to tell these
[__] primo
look at that they say that like a
[__] doctor so there you are you were
sitting there bored today thinking to
yourself what am i doing my life hey
this is California who gives a [__] you
what gives a [__] this is our ship we
pay taxes [__] I'm gonna smoke the
[__] joint somewhere that's all
[__] American right you understand me
it's number two under the Constitution
these [__] don't know these
people trying to scare you [__] you just
[__] join whatever the [__] you want
if they throw you under the [__] jail
least you died for a cause you
understand me sorry yeah I'm gonna rob a
car and listen from London skin it you
[__] [__] and that's what you
learned today American ingenuity and his
best let's do a little [__] fight
with a critical mass I want you to come
here for no reason you know I'm saying I
don't want to leave to come over and say
Jesus Christ we're smoking under the
critical mass Joe what the [__] were you
thinking that's the weed of life right
there well he was sweating his face was
red last night hey I came home I was
eating [__] pretzel sticks what was
the last time you ate [__] pretzel
sticks never
I love the people that write comments on
here my [__] you you fat slob tell you
something you [__] are watching
me [__] so we'll get your head
together you bored [__] on my
flappers tonight one show 9:15 the sets
tightening up a little bit for the
[__] special I got somewhere to go
now the name of the special is things
that keep me up at night so this is
perfect this is the [__] thread going
through tonight tomorrow night I'm at
the Melrose Improv eight o'clock and
sadly I'm at the Melrose Improv eight
o'clock who's better than you [__]
nobody [__] stay black Joey loves you
you [__] laying the new
podcasters up don't forget about us